[Music]
just cause you've had a good 13-year run
doesn't mean that there's not a young
lion who's about to use podcasting and
clubhouse
and linkedin and instagram to take your
business
[Music]
[Applause]
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
gary big jobber welcome to you thanks so
much for joining us today really
appreciate it
uh big fan thank you thank you and
you know i i really want to echo the q
and a part i'll set it up right now
i know the timing we have and i'll do my
15 to 20
up front but you know i was saying to my
dad
right you know because my kids are on
spring break so my parents
and my dad you know is a really a
construction man at heart and i was
giving him some context
to the incredible audience that's
watching right now
and he was we were laughing because he's
like well i i do a good job because i
need to i need all those things i need
hvac plumbing
landscaping uh building washing all that
stuff and so
but what was really interesting about
our conversation which is where i'm
going to start off with
for this talk is i am
you know i really associate with this
audience i
i have a really kind of fun career at
this point in my life and i get to be in
a lot of fancy fancy rooms
with a lot of high-tech thinkers and
politicians and all sorts of stuff and
the reality is is
for many of you that don't know who i am
let me give you a little context and
you'll understand why
i connect so much with this audience and
then more importantly how this combo i
just had with my dad
really ties into um where i want to go
with
leadership and opportunity really for
this audience so
i was born in the former soviet union i
came to the us
when uh i was three um lived in a very
immigrant household you know we didn't
come from a whole whole lot
it was uh extremely challenging uh
you know learning the language not
having money
you know being an 80s kid first grew up
in queens then dover
and then edison new jersey so you know
blue collar stuff
uh you know kind of grew up in that life
where i five
six seven eight nine ten years old i was
outside seventy percent of the time
getting into fights getting into trouble
um
playing sports learning my way learning
how to interact with people and
i was always a very heavy entrepreneur
you know it was just
in my blood and what was in my blood was
not only entrepreneurship but
much to the similarities of a lot of
people on this
call a lot of hand-to-hand combat
shoveling snow washing cars
by the time i was 14 my dad had lived
his american dream and
had gone from having no money and no
language to owning his own liquor store
um and worked his face off and had this
store that
i started working in and you know i
would
pack ice for five hours a day i would
stock shelves
carry boxes i still have a pretty bad
back soft tissue work fascia
for anybody whose back hurts look into
soft tissue work it's transformed my
life the last five years
anyway got a bad back from that really
worked that hard labor life
and you know the reality is that um
i i was able to get into my dad's
business
fall in love with wine collecting
which was an unusual thing for a
youngster to get
into but from 10 to 18
i was so deep in the baseball card
business
that i really fell in love with the idea
of collecting and flipping and selling
and
wine really became my next you know
passion once i realized that people did
the same thing with wine and so
um really got focused on that got very
passionate about that
and um and kind of built and built and
built
and through launching a website
through launching an email newsletter
through
starting a youtube show through being
social media first
email newsletter first but also doing
print and outdoor and radio and direct
mail
i was able to build my dad's local
liquor store business from a four to a
65 million dollar business
and that was a great accomplishment i
was very proud of that
um and game changing and
obviously changed my family's life and i
learned a lot there that i want to apply
to this keynote and really want to
invoke
the questions around it so one thing
that i'm very proud of is
at 22 years old when i went full time
into my dad's business
you know i became a leader immediately
my my dad was actually building this
house i'm sitting in now
uh back to my dad enjoying a lot of
things that all of you do uh
you know so he was kind of mia that
first year and that first year i really
took the business from like a 3.8 to a
10 million dollar business and it was
massive explosion and
so that was a culture shock and what
that really meant was
you know my dad was here building the
house and he'd come to the store which
is 40 minutes away
at like six or seven o'clock just to
check in at that point
me being 22 i'd already established a
ton of
confidence in my dad that i knew what i
was doing because i was in the store
since i was 14 so i was a veteran
so he didn't have to really check on me
and i was running the business and
i was managing 30 year olds 40 year olds
i
you know i had to have that
responsibility and every day from that
point to today 23 years later
for half my life now i've been the
leader of men and women
running a business today i run a company
called vaynerx which is a holding
company that
houses the company i run day to day as
ceo vaynermedia and many other companies
where
i have leaders in place a publishing
company called the gallery media group
vayner speaker is a speaking bureau
which i'm rep by for this talk
um you know vayner commerce and
e-commerce business a lot of businesses
and we have over 1500 people globally
singapore
london uh mexico city in a couple months
and that's and that's what i spend my
time on and and i lead and i lead and so
here are the things that i've learned
about leadership that isn't talked about
enough
oh you know my dad comes from the old
country
rules with an iron fist you know work
ethic
determination tenacity ambition
all incredibly great traits
um for leadership on the flip side what
my father didn't have
that i developed both between my natural
dna but definitely because of the
mothering that i was given
are things like empathy
and compassion and you know
um gratitude uh i think that humility is
a huge part of leadership
i think accountability let's start with
the cat let's start with the the one
that i'm most
passionate about accountability if
there's anything that i leave this talk
with
that maybe uh and when i do a talk like
this i'm like okay
you know if i can get one person
to act on one thing whether that's hey
for example i'm going to say this right
now
as a little side note in case i miss it
hey almost everybody here
should be posting one time a day on
linkedin
with a video picture or written word
with a tip
or a piece of content that's valuable to
the people in linkedin
even if you have no linkedin followers
even if you have no linkedin presence
everybody in this conference should be
doing linkedin content
marketing today because linkedin lets
you find people by accident
and that's incredibly unbelievable you
have no followers you post
and boom there you've got people seeing
your content
similar to facebook and twitter back in
2008 9 10 11.
you know if i can get one person to
leave with that today
dig in deeper or ask a question right
now around what what does that mean
that's a huge accomplishment for me in
this talk
and so the same thing goes with
accountability
i believe that most people hate
accountability they'd rather blame
somebody else
it's just the way it is and
i think it's a huge mistake i think no
question
the thing that has helped me the most in
my career is
realizing that every mistake that anyone
has ever made
is very interesting because
it's completely my fault because
i'm the person that hired them right if
sally or ricky or
tommy or karen or michael or jerome make
a mistake
and that's my fault i hired
them and i didn't have to
and i made the wrong call maybe in the
macro or they're having a bad day and
that's okay but it's about
the framework of first deciding that
you're wrong
and then focusing on what they do and i
think that has really helped me when
somebody
screws up that's when
leadership really kicks in you know i
say to my a lot of my leaders i'm like
look i don't need any peace time
generals i don't you know everyone's
good when everything's easy when the
money's flowing when customers are happy
when everything's good
everyone's a good leader show me what
you do when there's adversity
show me what you do when the pressure
comes on
that's when it gets most interesting to
me and that's to me pure leadership and
i would say that
most people are peacetime generals and
i'm looking for wartime generals
and that's what i think about
accountability and then i think about
empathy
i would argue that empathy a word that
i've never
heard growing up period let alone in
business
to me not only did karen or jerome or
sally or ricky or
jonathan make a mistake and not only am
i like okay that's my fault i put them
in that position
but then when i go to well why do they
do that is something going on in their
home life
is everything okay with them this
compassion empathy
so if you kind of go accountability
empathy and then
you focus on them you've now set up a
conversation
that has fruitfulness to be able to
actually get to resolution and more
importantly
build on and become scalable
you know i think about these ingredients
a lot of like success
i do think that um
curiosity is a huge one for me that i
would love to talk to this audience
about
i'm very curious how curious all of you
are
have you spent time trying to figure out
if linkedin can help
or does a podcast help or are you
curious of like yes my direct mail or my
print or my radio or my sales team has
worked for my business
but this digital thing you know have i
have you really gone there
have you have you just written it off
because you don't want to put
the work in of 30 to 40 hours to
become educated on these platforms
or have you you know
really spent those hours to be curious
and say
could youtube help my business you know
i wrote a book called crush it
in 2009 and then more recently three
years ago crushing it
an update to that book and it's shocking
to me
how much that
book impacted this audience i mean i get
plumbers and landscapers and
you know you know building washers
emailing me
multiple times a year saying that they
picked up the book and never thought
about social media being the driver
to their business and i think leadership
has set up
and i appreciate the way this talk is
being set up is
by doing and having people follow your
actions
it's hard to inspire your organization
to be more progressive in its marketing
if you yourself uh have not
really gone there aren't really about it
uh dismiss it or kind of do it because
you spent a couple dollars on it because
you think you got to do it
but you really don't deep down believe
in it
i think that's something you really need
to pay attention to and
and a huge mistake for a lot of family
businesses and businesses
uh in this ecosystem that i've seen over
and over a complete
lack of curiosity um complacency
this is how we've always done it this is
what worked for me
i've only got another eight years of
this anyway so who gives a crap
i'm not gonna need to learn this
facebook instagram thing huge mistake
you know the entrepreneurship business i
think all of you know this
you know i commend all of you to be on
this if you're on this if you're seeing
this
you've done it you're in a very small
group of people that have been able to
stand on their own two feet
live their life on their own two feet i
commend that
i also remind you that it's a jungle out
here and
just because you've had a good 13-year
run doesn't mean that there's not a
young lion
who's about to use podcasting and
clubhouse and linkedin and
instagram to take your business you know
history
the past doesn't care about the current
and vice versa just because you had a
good run as being the guy
in this neighborhood for this skill set
doesn't mean that there's not somebody
trying to
take it and build a reputation and take
market share and so
you know i'm very passionate around
curiosity i think it's
huge now i'm going to segue before we go
to q
a and i know i'm about 12 minutes in
which leaves me about five to eight
minutes left to
talk and then i want to go into q a so
please start gathering your questions
around
management managing managers social
media marketing
things of that nature but let me keep
giving you some stuff let me give you
let me be a little naked here and talk
about something i've struggled with
on stage and as garyvee
if you follow my content this will blow
your mind i'm great at candor
right i can be very candace here in the
q a i'm about to be very candace i'm
candace and this
i'm very candace as a character on
instagram
you know my content i mean just let me
just see what i've
posted recently like this this school
you know this school video i'm very very
candace
i'm very very very very candace you know
in
as you can tell and potty mouth and
jerseyed out
but as a manager of people i so
struggled with delivering bad news that
i danced
i danced i was a little full of [ __ ] to
be frank i couldn't deliver the hey rick
you suck
at your job let's fix this or to say
that i would dance i would try to pep up
i would
i would be pep rally but i wouldn't be
canderous
and then what would happen is i'd
eventually be fed up and i would fire
rick
and he'd be stunned because a week ago
i'm like go rick go r-i-c-k
rick rick rick and then i'm like and
then on you know and then on friday
on tuesday i'm cheerleading squad and on
friday i'm like we gotta let you go
and rick would be like what and i would
always be anxious and i realize now why
because
i didn't set it up i wasn't candorous
enough
so one of my key tenets ingredients to
leadership
is kind candor i think people use
candor as an excuse to be mean and to
rear their insecurities and talk down to
people and so i don't love that
and which is why i call it kind candor
not candor
you have to be able to deliver feedback
to people and you need to be kind about
it for example one of the things i would
say say look
sally in my opinion and you know
unfort and i use this unfortunately this
company is mine
and it's my responsibility unfortunately
to make a subjective call from what i've
seen and what i feel
unfortunately i don't feel like you're
very strong at this and we need to talk
about it
so you're you're hedging the candor with
kindness
you know rick you you're just a pleasure
in this office you're you're bringing so
much value
to the office culture you know i'm
getting some complaints from the clients
that you're missing some t's and dotting
missing some dotting of eyes
we need to talk about this because that
keeps happening it's gonna be
vulnerability should maybe you should
maybe not be a cow person maybe you want
to be in hr today or maybe you want to
do something
like kind candor kind candor really
matters
um i used to use stunning people then
big severances
then you know feeling bad and like
overextending myself after i would fire
them all bad behavior
all because i wasn't able to be
cancerous it was a huge
huge leadership flaw of mine and it's
the one that i'm most building up right
now that i'm proud of
and so kind candor i think is another
thing that a lot of people here have to
talk about
um that's something humility just for a
few minutes before we go into q a
you know i've been very fortunate in my
career
i really have i've had a lot of
accolades you start googling me now if
you don't know there's a lot of
winning stuff out there but
having the ambition to be all time but
and equally in your body knowing you
don't mean [ __ ]
is a huge thing and a huge huge factor
to leadership
i definitely believe that more people in
my company buy into me
because of my humility which is again i
would argue my humility and my inability
to have candor are the two things my
content is least capable of
communicating
but are two foundational things that
have
impacted my leadership one negatively
lack of candor
now in the last 18 months it's exploded
my kind candor and it's really helped my
company and b
humility like you know i only think i'm
as good as my last at-bat
so just because i invested in facebook
and twitter and uber and pinterest and
snapchat and coinbase
and venmo and have this great investing
career my next investment tomorrow
might suck and could really hurt me you
know just because i
you know um just because i
have built this 200 million plus company
vaynerx
you know in revenue from zero doesn't
mean tomorrow that it can't go down to
87
if i get high on my own supply and think
i'm a tough guy and think i'm so great
and think i'm harry v humility is
incredibly important and people
smell it on you and i think a lot of you
could have a lot more success
if you didn't need to take credit for
everything that your team's doing
humility really matters and i think it
really rears its head and i highly
recommend you get
into an honest place self-awareness
which is where i'm going to end and then
we're going to go into q a so please
start firing those questions away
because oh you ready yeah i love that
you jumped in
um you know let me just stand with this
software do you have a good amount of
questions at this point i just want to
call it go ahead finish yeah i'm going
to finish this but i want to i'm glad
you jumped in because i want to make
sure that people come with the questions
because i think
as you can imagine everybody who's
watching right now this is very macro
what i'm talking about and the reason i
love q
a is i'm thrilled that you're like yeah
that's right yeah that's right yeah
that's right but i love making it like
no no yesterday jose yelled at me what
do i do or like or i got this
opportunity to merge with another like
so i'm excited about the questions you
can go
anywhere with me on any business
question but sticking on
leadership self-awareness yeah you know
it took me
being self-aware challenging myself
willing to be honest with myself
that hey gary you think you're so great
and you're so nice and you're so
successful this candor thing is a
problem and it took
it took pain it took people not liking
me
which was makes no sense because my
intent is through the roof i'm like
so lucky and so well parented that i
love people
i don't need nothing from nobody i'm on
my own two feet i ask i
i don't need anything and not
emotionally not financially and yet i
still had these individuals who were
miffed
and would talk [ __ ] about me and i was
like god damn it it's that candor
so self-awareness you've got to really
really deploy that
let me leave you with this sentence and
we'll go right into q a
every strength and every weakness you
have as a leader you're tricking no one
they know you're employees now your
customers know
your employees know and if they don't
know they themselves don't have good
emotional intelligence
and i always said to my friends you'd
rather win with winners
than win with losers right and so like
if you're
tricking people that don't know your
employees are also
insecure and this is like an unhealthy
relationship cool but you're just
building an ecosystem
that's going to be small and and more
importantly if somebody is
emotionally intelligent both on your
customer side or your employee side
they're going to see right through you
so see right through yourself first i
always say i'd rather put myself
out of business than have somebody else
do it you know i got ahead of it and had
a very heart-to-heart conversation with
my company and said look i'm lacking
candor and that's why we're b minus we
should be a plus culture
because of what my intent is i can make
money elsewhere i don't make decisions
on every
dollar i'm a good guy i want legacy not
currency i got all this going for me but
we're a b minus that was because
of this lack of candor i'm standing up
this thing called kind candor
so everybody who's in here who's a
little bit of like a little bit of a
jerk
this doesn't mean you're gonna be able
to get to be a jerk this is gonna mean
that
we're gonna be more candice with each
other and it's really changed my company
and i'm using something in my life to
give you the courage to be self-aware of
you know for example maybe you're 62 and
your work ethic isn't where it was from
18 to 60 and
or 55 and guess what you deserve it you
work for 37 27 years off your face
like but you're not tricking your people
that you're nine to threeing it
and when you come in and you feel guilty
about them you're like you got to work
like you got to be careful you got to
say you got to be honest about it you
got to say look
i i bled out of my eyeballs for 33 years
for the luxury to be able to nine to
three it
i'll you know you need to and that that
kind of stuff so anyway i really
appreciate everybody i hope everybody's
doing well
and i'm excited for the q a
that was amazing gary thanks uh thanks
so much i mean before we go into q a
what stood out for you right you said
before i went on
i'm a fan you know i touched on some
stuff that i don't normally talk about
because i wanted to really deliver
something unique for you did anything
for you personally what
what hit you know i think i i think a
lot
about these sort of you know topics of
leadership and
and sort of you know how you know the
behavior of
a leader really impacts and affects the
culture of an organization and i think
you
you really kind of pulled out you know
this these ideas around
you know how your dad did it and he's
he's obviously been really successful
and sort of
hard work grit tenacity really important
characteristics but i think
the the modern approach needs to balance
that with
empathy compassion gratitude humility
accountability i think
success uh today both in terms of
organizations and people
and financially which kind of comes
downstream of organizational and
people's success
really requires that kind of a balance
and hearing you talk about that
stood out because i think it's something
that that we spend a lot of time
thinking about and and
um trying to understand where's that
balance how do we build a culture that
that really and a culture i'm certain
and a culture that if some you know i
always say look
i don't want to make you be anything but
you so if you're
19 let me use my company if you're 24
and you came from a low income family
but you were a good student which got
you a full ride to a good university and
you've had a chip on your shoulder your
whole life that you want to make that
money
right and you come to vayner and you
want to work
10 hours a day instead of eight like
everybody else because you want to use
that as an advantage to get
how could i be a hypocrite when that's
what i did so i'm gonna support that
on the flip side if you're a
working mom at vayner and you're 41
and you now you have you got two young
kids and you want to have a little more
work-life balance
i don't want to penalize you for nine to
five
i'm gonna i'm gonna judge you on the
impact not on
you know and i want you to feel just the
same i want the 24 year old that wants
to bleed for a decade
to build and the 45 year old guy or
gal who wants work life that like i want
them to both feel safe
in my ecosystem and i think the number
one thing that a leader needs to do is
create safety i really believe that
make people feel safe yeah
that's that's great i think we have way
more questions than we're going to get
through yeah we're going to go fast
a great way of generating i think the
first one is um and and i think this is
great because i i wasn't really aware of
this this
history and hand-to-hand combat i love
that sort of characterization
um you know kind of really getting that
that sort of ground-up experience and
you know now leading an organization of
1500 people 200 million dollars
um i think that um oh the first question
swapped
so uh nevermind it's not relevant to
that but that history i think is a
really interesting arc that gives you
perspective sort of across the range
which is super interesting so
first question uh from joshua asks um
and
a lot of people like this question as
well how do you discern having empathy
for
your staff uh without being taken
advantage of
from them um because by by realizing
you're the boss
you can't be by nature if you're their
boss
and you have say and you can fire you
can't be taken advantage of
like it's a right it's a very powerful
thought i get this question a lot so i'm
glad a lot of people wanted to hear it
you just might have the same issue i had
for most of my career your inability to
be candorous
your your hate of conflict your hate of
that
moment makes you think you're getting
taken advantage of because you're not
firing i mean there's people i said
brother there's people that i didn't
fire for three years
seven years in my mind so i know where
people are coming from and a lot of
people in this call
are family businesses this i mean some
of these people that are taking
advantage of
are their nephews and they're kind of
like there's i know what again
to your point one of the great
advantages of my career is i'm almost
like a line chat like i'm almost like a
dishwasher boy that went up to own
one of the biggest restaurant chains
like i've lived everything
and so it gives me perspective and i've
lived in family businesses and in
corporate like i've got a good breath at
this point
small business corporate silicon valley
like i've
i'm i'm happy where i'm at from a gray
hairs perspective i've been in a lot of
rooms so it's a great question but let
there be no confusion
you can't be taken advantage of you're
in control by the way in life you can't
most people say gary my kindness gets me
walked all over i'm like you're letting
that happen
you know what's crazy i know a lot of
people do it to manipulate the outcome
they like to cry that they're being
taken advantage of but they're equally
in a manipulative relationship
and and they for example they'll use it
as an excuse to not give people a raise
like there's a lot there if we're going
to get real with each other like we are
right now you know so
rest assured if you're the boss you
can't be taken advantage of because you
can fire the second you're fed up with
it
yeah i think it comes back to
accountability and the point you make
there i mean if
you if that happens like that's you you
should ask us whose fault is it
no no it's a everything in life is your
fault and
when you understand that life gets
awesome that doesn't mean that
that the government doesn't do crap that
doesn't mean that there's not sexism and
racism that doesn't mean that
your dad wasn't an alcoholic it's like
of course things happen
but when you fall in love with
accountability it makes you feel like
you're in control
which is a hell of a lot more fun than
dwelling about the world
[ __ ] you yeah that's a great point
okay daryl asks how do you attract great
people
to unsexy industries um
we're looking for you know young hungry
sales people
uh but really having challenges
competing against local tech
uh sales market that you know offer
these you know really kind of hot
industries exciting environments
uh how do you balance that how do you
figure that out you have to storytell
you have to put out content
have to put out content um
and you have to put it out on linkedin
you have to put it out on instagram
and you gotta give them what you got and
say look
i'll give you an example a boss that's
charismatic in the video
who's like look i know there's some hot
stop you know
companies here in milwaukee big shout
out to tech tech tech
you know but look we are an awesome
environment
we have a great family environment here
you can make a ton of money
you can learn your skill sets you know
this is a great place to craft your
skill
we have a 50-year track record we can
you can train up
learn your skill and then if you want to
do other things cool like you got to
make it about them
not about you and too many people are
like oh this is bull like everybody's
angry old men that's [ __ ] the tag
they try to like [ __ ] on it they're like
that tech's not going to be around in a
couple years
it doesn't work it's all defense you
have to go pure offense
we have this we have this we have this
and then you
make up stuff look maybe you create a
super bonus i gave a friend a tip that
crushed for him
i was like make up something called the
super bonus this year
and make content around he got a ton of
sales people because of it he just
invented a
a ad hoc bonus at the end of the year
that if this certain number and it
worked
what was even crazier is and then it was
hit he made it up as outer space
and they hit it which you know really
taught him about carrots and
ambition and so i i my overall answer is
content and offense you know speak on
your strengths
you know family business family
environment you can really learn here
tried and true
30 years 20 years i'll care you know not
you know either like that kind of stuff
that's great
yeah get off the defense get on the
offense i think that's uh
yeah let's listen back to everybody
who's watching right now
yes you're not building the next
instagram but you have a sustained
business that's real and again
lean into human stuff like if you make a
video
on linkedin you're like look what's
great about our company is
we have three sales leaders who've been
with me for 15 years
a lot of you youngsters could use
mentors come in here and learn a lot be
taken care of don't be just a number
you know we may not have a foosball
table and kombacha but like
you're gonna learn [ __ ] like and there's
a ton of kids you know it's funny
you know obviously i spend a lot of time
in this there's a lot of kids that are
anti-millennial gen z kid
dna like there's like even within their
own ranks
of like 18 to 25 21 to
27 they're really funny with each other
there's a lot of kids that do think
the other kids are way too fluffy and i
think they'll resonate to some of that
old world stuff
yep that's great okay the next question
comes from aaron this is the one that i
that i thought was great and given this
the range that you have
um so so aaron asks carrie i'm just
getting involved in my husband's
landscape business
uh while he's a very good entrepreneur i
have more of a corporate background
what suggestions do you have for me as i
shift my thinking and mindset from a
business manager
such a great question yeah um so i see
this a lot
a lot and um
it's funny i'm working on a book right
now uh
that is coming out in november that's
really around all these themes and i do
a lot of
make pretend scenarios and i have a
scenario
very similar to this so it's fun first
you have to deploy empathy
so many husbands to wives and wives to
husband and they're you know
luckily we're in 2021 where i see a ton
of emails and questions
that come from both sides of this the
corporate person the husband or wife
has to have a ton of humility and
empathy because a lot of times
when you were a successful corporate
type that was good at school
you you were groomed to look down at the
scrappy entrepreneur now it's changing
but we all
most of us over 30 grew up in an
environment
so what the big mistake i see a lot of
times is that people come with
corporate ideas for small businesses and
they're completely tone deaf
you know making decks making charts
having these strat like
all the [ __ ] that i do with in
corporate william it doesn't work for a
small business
so the number one recommendation i
always give is humility and empathy
and patience you have to come in
and for three months not say a word
and just listen let your you know for
this exact question let your husband
show you the ropes on everything then
take a step back through your filter and
have ideas once you tasted it
it's like being a sushi chef and coming
to
you know a french cuisine place yes
you're like you've done business
but this is a totally different cuisine
and you've got to really
really really take a step back and maybe
that's not a good analogy it's like
going from being a sushi chef to working
at a single serve
fast food restaurant sure it's food but
it's really different
and so i think that humility patience
and empathy
are the two things i deploy if i'm that
corporate person
listen for three to six months then your
words will carry a ton more weight
so many uh partners get into friction
because the one cup
the one partner that comes from the
corbett landscape comes with hypotheses
that are not practical to a day-to-day
entrepreneurial business
and then there's frustration
yeah that's humility and empathy i mean
it's almost like those
those principles can kind of answer most
of the questions that what
you might come up with it's it's funny
it's what i spent my last five years
thinking about so i wrote this book i
have a book coming up called 12 and a
half it's the ingredients for success
and when i
why i wrote it in that format it is like
a meal ironically based on my last
analogy
it's not just one it's not just humility
because without empathy and compassion
for the other person and without
patience
to eat [ __ ] for six months she can't be
successful you need
multiple things it's not just ambition
you need tenacity right like yeah i'm
gonna make it well cool
what happens on thursday like on a day
like this it's gloomy as [ __ ]
right like i don't know you're not
motive you know like but how do you
grind
through that
yep it's great we have we have time for
one more question
i think and there are we i think we got
to about one percent of them
so listen real quick on that front
everybody i'm on linkedin
or if you're on twitter garyvee or if
you're on instagram garyvee feel free to
direct message
i'll try to get to some but go ahead my
friend awesome thank you so christine
wants to know
um she is you know badly wants to get
more confident in short videos
uh for other businesses for social media
they own an exterior cleaning company
they've got great relationships with
their employees and their customers
but she's just really insecure
documenting all the great things that
happen how does she get over that where
did she start
um getting more comfortable with that
that daily post that daily tip
living your life and making decisions
based on other people's judgments
is the quickest way to be unhappy you
know like the real reality of this one
is very simple do you believe at 88
years old
92 years old 94 years old when you're
kind of
wrapping it up do you honestly think
that somebody leaving a comment
on your linkedin or facebook video that
said you're ugly
or that was stupid or you're wrong do
you really think that's going to carry
weight
think of it as this way everybody on
this call got made fun of in second or
third or fourth grade
sixth grade about something is that
something you're really like
carrying today as like this devastating
moment the answer's no
and so i just try to encourage people
based on real life
that you know your aunt or your mom or
your uncle or your best friend
or a former employee or your neighbor or
your high school friend's
joke or insensitive comment on your
video
or the lack of any comments this is back
to humility brother i did a
i did 50 to 100 episodes of wine library
tv before anybody gave a [ __ ]
i had humility and i had tenacity i knew
it was right
you asking this question to me you know
it's right you know these videos will
help your business
who cares like like like again
people worry about their looks people
worry about them stumbling on words like
it just doesn't matter and i have to you
know this is why i put out content every
day like
it's like i'm trying to beat this into
people's head like really
like other people's judgment when people
leave negative comments on your content
that's a reflection on their unhappiness
think about that this is a person who
has time like i don't have time to
do anything people have time to go to
somebody else's page
and try to make them feel bad that's
deep pain
when you're trying to tear down other
people you were in deep
pain the end
the end that's the empathetic answer
again those principles i mean have
empathy for that person
like why are they why are they spending
their time that way it's always about
the other person you focus on your stuff
do what you want all the good and bad or
you know
i'll leave with this you want a really
good way to deal with booing
stop getting high on the cheering what
has absolutely kept me in a great place
is i get a lot of cheering
you know i'm very grateful i get stupid
levels of accolades
on a daily basis uh you know i'm proud
to say i think they're warranted
based on how i navigate but i don't
believe
them and i definitely don't hear them
and what i mean by that is
i don't think i'm special i think i'm
trying to give
which people react to and then i think
when you don't hear the cheering it's a
lot easier to not hear the booing
so stay in that middle place as you
navigate your
leadership your your teamwork and
definitely your content and content
is the breakthrough for everybody here i
have no idea what the rest of the
agendas are and talks but please my
friends make videos
show people your work you're not giving
away secrets your competitors are not
going to steal it
get yourself out there on facebook and
linkedin it will change your business
it's great and by the way one last thing
if you're funny
if you're funny and or and or
if you have eight to 20 year old kids
and you're willing to you know i i do
but i don't [ __ ] we don't share our
personal life but if you
want to and you do tick-tock if you
could be the fun
funny landscaper if you could be the
funny plumber
i mean if you can dance i'm not i'm
being very you know i'm being really
serious here you would be
shocked how the world actually works you
know yeah
people love it awareness snack they're
like oh who is that they go on your
profile
wait i'm in buffalo like dm this guy hey
i love your videos
by the way i have a major you know issue
with my well
you know like you know like it's how it
works
it's awesome okay so that's all the time
we got for for q a today
thank you gary thanks so much for
helping us kick off uh the jobber pda i
think
you know i i think i can speak for for
the home service community
thousands of people that are watching
today when i say that um you know we
really appreciate
these you know words of inspiration you
kind of talking to this
piece of the small business community i
think the entrepreneurs you spoke to
today they're they're often overlooked
when people talk about small businesses
everyone's talking about restaurants and
stuff like that and uh
you're helping to change that so thank
you thank you and real quick because i
see it because i see people using the
hashtag
jabber p-day uh denise thank you so much
for saying that and
jacob said how do you incentivize
employees within a small business with
limited resources
i know i don't want to go too late but i
just want to give one last nugget it's
through the emotional relationship when
i had nothing to give when i only had 10
employees
i gave my friendship i gave my heart i
gave who i was as a human
by being a friend it's not just about
money and or empty promises one day
you're going to own a piece of this
business it's like
you know there's just other things that
you can do
start a softball team right like you
know there's like things like
there's clever things yup awesome cheers
everyone
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you